you
how's it going guys we're doing a lab
today a C++ lab on code tech tutorials
here and I'm doing this on a whim so I
have not seen any of this I've not
prepared and I'm giving myself a
challenge with 20 minutes to complete
this lab whatever it may be so I've got
the timer started and let's go ahead and
check out some labs so I basically just
googled C++ labs for beginners or
something along those lines I forget
exactly what at Google and I got this so
this is what we're looking at and we're
gonna pick one of these and we're going
to complete it from start to finish I'm
on a Windows computer I'm gonna use
cygwin to compile with C++ and a Linux
like environment though you can use
whatever you want if you're following
along Visual Studio should work fine
okay so here's these labs which one to
pick there's a flow of control library
functions user-defined functions single
dimensions I could do any of these all
these initially sound pretty easy to me
I should know how to do them pretty
quickly so I should be able to teach
them as I go that's kind of the goal
here all right let's just oh geez
there's so many there's a set one two
and three where do we start boys where
do we start if you're watching this
video leave a comment because I don't
know suggest a new one for next time and
maybe I'll do one that gets a lot of up
votes or something let's let's do one
that's I don't know start from the
beginning it might be too easy that was
my concern but if I can complete this in
like 20 minutes I mean that's the time
what if I can complete this in like five
minutes let's try it was check out set
one and let's see what we get write a
program to print hello world on the
screen okay
that's super easy so we can do that part
okay
I'm in a labs folder I'm gonna make a
directory called what was this called
I'll call it
variable operator and expression set one
is what it's called
okay so they got the solutions here I'm
not gonna look at these solutions though
I'm gonna write my own solutions I guess
that's part of the point all right let's
make it a directory called I'll just
call this bars set one underscore set
one okay
I'm going to spend more time creating
variables our creating variable names
that I am actually coding not
intentially okay so we're in this now
what we can do is we can open the visual
studio code in this folder
and we get you know nothing so we can
just make new files or we could also
touch new files like this yeah I could
use them or something but I'm not going
for that right now we're not going that
hardcore let's just make a main dot cpp
okay and we're also going to you know
this is fine we got a hurry so we're
gonna include iostream and then we're
gonna make an end to main we don't need
to take anything and we just do a
standard and see out hello world a new
line there at the end and we can return
0 since we're supposed to return an
integer and there we go okay so that'll
will print hello world and all caps they
have it like this so if we run that we
just go see g+ + main dot cpp and then
after that we'll run it with a dot I
think it's a dot exe list it's a 1
narrow runs so compiles after compiles
it runs and runs whole world spits out
looks fine okay we completed the very
first thing wasn't that super fun all
right write a program to display the
following output using a single C out
statement okay
subject marks mathematics okay yeah
that's that's actually super easy as
well a single C out so let's go ahead
and knock that out so after the hello
world we'll just do it in a new one we
gotta get that
exact words all right so we want subject
and we want I don't know what I want
spaces tabs we'll do it with some spaces
and marks and then we want a new line
here and we want to continue the same
see out statement we can do it like so
notice there's no semicolon in there and
then we can say mathematics and we can
give I don't know how many spaces we
need doesn't look like they haven't
lined up perfect either so I'm just
gonna go for it here and basically do
this a few times so this is a pretty
simple thing computer just plain old
computer chemistry so this is some is
some basic level super easy stuff right
here and then we do need in this
semicolon at the end there and now then
won't return zero so let's go ahead and
run that same command compile and run
and there we go looks great let's go
ahead and the next one write a program
which accepts two numbers and prints
their sum okay very good we've done this
previous videos let's go ahead and go
down to here and do that so we'll say
input number cow people i'll do a
calculate sum notice for the user and
then we'll say enter first number and
we'll have this thing in like so oh no
new line there so it prompts right at
the end of that and then we'll do is we
needed a number here I will do a float
two numbers it says two numbers see I
will do floats float num one way and
then we'll go standard see and num one
that was prompt for it and then we'll do
the same thing with num2 so I'm just
gonna copy all this double down to the
control D of course we want in our
second number here we need a standard C
out there of course formatting
formatting okay
so there's an her first number and
there's an her second number and what do
we do next or is that enough together
and we'll just say I'm one we'll do a
plus symbol and then we'll do num2 and
then we'll do an equal symbol and then
we'll do a result which we can calculate
right in line here surrounded with
frenzies which isn't actually required
let him do it anyway and then a new line
at the end or a new newline character
what's the single quotes because it's a
little more efficient and there we go
that should complete that requirement
and we're just gonna run this oops I'm
fin I need to do this command I'm used
to having make files with an make run in
our first node okay so did all our
previous stuff and then it's asking for
calculate some we're gonna give it a 5
and we'll give it a slice at first
number twice whoops so this should say
second number you guys probably noticed
that while you're watching but anyway
that'll correct it in there we go looks
great so we could do it with decimal
numbers since it's flow very good so we
could make comments here if you're doing
this in a real lab you might be doing
something like that professor might want
you there whatever you know lab
instructor we'd say like one you know to
they'd get the point and usually they
want a common block at the top so you
might have something like
your name and then pan out whatever
about the project lab one step one and
maybe professors name class whatever but
this isn't like that I'm just giving you
I don't know why that's how it was for
means that's how it was for me when I
was doing computer science anyway and
that's insane general good practice
let's see what do we have we got we got
some time left well maybe we can get
through this whole set it's actually
taking a little bit of time because I'm
kind of explaining things so maybe that
will help some people out that are very
new to all this okay write a program
which accepts temperature in Fahrenheit
and prints it and centigrade okay very
good okay that's easy we'll do we'll
copy some of this and we'll say and you
know what we might even want to scope
this I'm sorry I'm going back a little
bit here but just for example if we
really want to have these sectioned off
we want to scope them and that's because
we're declaring variables so once it
gets past the scope the the variables go
out of scope and they're no longer used
so it's just a way of like sectioning
off your program it's sort of an
advanced thing you don't really have to
do that at this point we honest but it
might be a good habit to get into I
don't know what the auto formatting key
is on this editor and yeah I guess I
really don't need to do it on the C outs
and it doesn't even make any sense but
at home declaring variables it sort of
does in some situations if you don't
like your variables to bleed down that
way you can potentially reuse the names
which isn't actually recommended process
either so yeah that was a whole lot of
things about scoping but these brackets
basically do a scope in case you didn't
know that okay so I for write a program
it's accepts temperature and calculate
f2c I'll just say that okay and
Fahrenheit
I just bail that I temp okay so
basically we get the Fahrenheit tip temp
here so we'll do a float and we'll call
it f F temp for now and then we'll just
do a standard C cn
all right so that should get it and on
my spelling ray I'm spelling wrong
so that will retrieve the variable from
our console input and then we need to do
a calculation and spit it out and we'll
basically say after Tim and I keep
spelling it wrong and we'll make a
little symbol we'll put an F here too is
and then okay and then we'll have our
centigrade here I'll just put a start a
couple stars there for now that's dummy
text so I guess I got sound on the back
quotes actually so we need to fill out
the formula there basically and this is
going to teach us a little about
formulas so f temp is blank centigrade
and it'll basically say when we're done
so we need to actually get this formula
what is Fahrenheit to centigrade I never
remember it so we can always Google it
with Fahrenheit to centigrade formula
and there you go so here is the formula
and if we want to write that in C++
we're just going to make sure it goes in
the proper order of operations so it
looks like we can do it all in line here
we'll put in parentheses
okay so it is whatever the Fahrenheit is
so f temp - 32 and then what any part
room run out of space there we go
okay F temp so the Fahrenheit
temperature then you - 32 then you take
the result of that and times it by 5
divided by 9
it's weird five dot F
bye-bye and we'll do these floats so
they divide a little better so we take
the result of five dot okay so yeah we
take the result of this and we basically
times brothers all that and we'll get to
temperature yeah okay so let's give it a
test I'm gonna have a new line here and
a semicolon and let me just widen that
up so you can see it a little bit but
that that should work
so that'll spit out that variable right
there as it calculates on the line we
could even put another set of
parentheses around it used to be super
clear that that's all one thing so the
way the order of operations works is it
goes the most inner parentheses first
and otherwise it goes left to right so
it doesn't actually care about the
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally stuff
that cares about parentheses so you got
to really work with your parentheses to
make sure it goes in the right order
that's the big thing to remember when
doing in C++ and let's go ahead and run
this and let's see if we get a valid
answer here we got the whole calculate
number garbage I'm gonna I'm gonna stop
this by just commenting it out so we
don't get prompted we want to go to the
fahrenheit prompt here we go so
Fahrenheit prompt so if we put in a
temperature of 60 degrees Fahrenheit it
spits out that it's fifteen point five
five six degrees Celsius let's put that
in here and just check our answer so if
it's 60 yep there we go it's 15 point
five by five so very good got the
calculator temp going on there and now
we will comment that out and I'm just
gonna go ahead and go to the next one
looks like we've got about five minutes
left I don't think we're gonna finish
these but maybe I'll do a second video
if people enjoy this sort of thing
because I could go through this entire
set of labs and I would probably be able
to explain every little thing maybe that
would be helpful some people out there I
am a tutorial channel so that's my
overall intention okay let's see here
five write a program that accepts
principal rate and time from a user and
prints the simple interest okay this is
a good one so this is something that you
might want to do on on your own when
you're doing investments let's see
principal rate and time from the user
and print the simple interest so I need
to look up the exact definition of
simple interest but we're gonna have to
go ahead and just will tell the user
it's always good if you're doing a
console thing may need to be telling
your user somehow what they're actually
doing calc simple interest now what is
simple interest is out like a yearly
rate a monthly rate I don't know I guess
they were prompting for rate so we need
to look into that what are we looking
for months weeks days years I guess
we'll assume years so this I kind of
need a little more details or I could
just make up some to really
I guess I could do a quick Google search
I should probably be able to solve that
okay so we need principal so we'll go
ahead and do you see out for principal
so this would be like that
thanks principal Prince something wrong
I know it's better I'll give me this
copy paste coders - all right so yeah in
that and then we need that then we want
a to declare a variable for this so I'll
float print well if you want more
accuracy you can use doubles and set up
floats and by default most compilers
will set your variables to 0 at the
start but if you're worried about them
not and setting them to something else
you can set equal 0 but I'm skipping
that here because mine already does that
all right so float principle and we want
oh we need the rate and we need the time
and then we're just gonna stand there I
guess yeah I'm all gonna declare them
all at once I could declare them one at
a time as I need them oh this is CN and
we want the principal here and then
we're gonna standard C out we want
actually we need a new line here because
after we accept principal we want the
rate and we're gonna accept that rate
with a CN I'm going to stand do it some
copy-paste save a little time this will
be rate in this next line here we're
going to want time so this /n is a new
line of course and the time let's copy
this real quick time well I don't know
why I changed to that there we go so the
variable time some of the if you name
stuff really simple things eventually
we'll run into something that's reserved
so you got to watch out for those
reserved words like if you try to name
something Khan for example I believe
Khan is reserved in some OS as so stuff
like that but this is fine for now just
so you're aware that that's the thing
let's see okay so now we just need to do
the calculation so based on what they
gave us
we just need to spit out the calculation
of whatever that simple interest is so
let me actually Google simple interest
because I don't know what that means
there it is okay so final amount is what
we're looking for so we got a principal
balance and you've got an interest
interest rate which is our our number of
times interest is applied and we don't
really have that I guess well I don't I
don't know number of time periods
elapsed so we're missing a little info I
don't know how many times this interest
is supposed to be applied for time
period so we'll just kind of go with it
and see if we can get a pretty close
answer so we'll say interest will say
final final amount and then we'll just
do our formula and it looks like our
formula yeah this needs to be a little
more verbose and be a little more clear
if we were doing it like super
accurately because we want y22 new
months or we might need to calculate it
specifically today's so we're just gonna
do the formula basically initial
principal balance so we'll have prints
yeah well basically just write out this
formula here there's principal and then
that's all going to be times by 1 plus
rate times the time now we want the rate
and time to be calculated before that
plus 1 C++ won't necessarily do that so
that's one of those things that you just
gotta kind of address by using
parentheses so we encapsulate that to
make sure it resolves first rate times
time and then in this it looks like I'm
out of time so I'll finish this one up
and then we'll end it there
all righty let's see and I will continue
the next one if if this gets more views
in my usual videos I suppose and then we
should be able get a final amount there
now this is gonna look a little weird
because we're not going into fine detail
about this but it is what it is you
probably see the point and you could
probably clean it up a little more okay
so let's say we had five thousand bones
and at the rate of interest where I'll
say at one point two percent interest
and over two of the time well maybe
that's years there we go look look at
that oh that might be I think that's
calculating into a thousand print
percent interest or a hundred
102 percent I don't know it's uh so it
ends up we have 17 grand at the end of
that period but yeah it's not real clear
what these rates are this is just years
decades is this a hundred and two
percent or is this yeah so anyway you
get the point so you could clean it up
more with a little more research on
principle but that in general solves it
for for that all right well thank you
very much for watching I'll see you guys
in the next video and keep on coding if
you want to see more stuff like this and
keep going just let me know peace out